how long do you wait for people
so it's thursday it's my uh
meeting day and i had a great meeting at
starbucks with an entrepreneur
got my soy smoothie right here and then
the second meeting i had it back to back
didn't show up and that happens every
now and then and uh
for personal meetings face to face i
give a 15 minute buffer
if i haven't heard from you and you
don't show up 15 minutes and then i'm
out i got other things to do so i'm on
my way back
to uh have other meetings and google
hangouts and
answer emails and all that fun stuff if
it's a phone call
it's usually five minutes so what i'll
do is if i have a call
i'll call the person so i'm always doing
the calling so i'll call the person
and if they don't answer i leave a
voicemail so i'll come back in a couple
minutes
and then i'll call back in five minutes
and if they don't answer again that's it
i'll leave a message saying let's set up
another time and i move on to other
stuff like
maybe making a video like this or doing
other fun things
with my day so i'm curious to know how
long you wait
for somebody either for a phone meeting
or for an in-person meeting
i've got my five-minute rule on the
phone 15-minute rule
in person let me know what you think in
the comments below
and believe
if you want the real goods i share my
best advice for entrepreneurs every week
in my newsletter
click the link below to check it out
it's free